la victime est décédée par noyade
mais fait plus étonnant
les médecins relèvent des blessures sur
le torse de Lucas François
9 côtes cassées au total
pour les enquêteurs il y aurait donc eu
une violente bagarre entre Eric et Lucas
Cagnes-sur-Mer dans le midi de la France
André Sommer ancien officier de marine
prépare sa valise
demain il part pour les Caraïbes mais
pour lui pas question de vacances il va
voir son fils
Eric en prison accusé de meurtre
voilà j'ai amené quelques livres aussi
pour Eric parce que bon voilà j'ai pensé
qu'il fallait qu'il médite un petit peu
lui aussi j'y vais parce que ça fait
déjà pas mal de temps où je suis pas
allé et j'ai senti quand même chez Eric
que
son courage à ces frites un petit peu
quoi
cela fait près de trois ans qui réclame
son innocence il attend toujours d'être
jugé
il y a eu des hauts et des bas il y a eu
des fois tout à fait au début où on me
laissait penser que la fois d'après il y
aura un dénouement heureux mais il y
aura un dénouement le comble c'est de ne
pas avoir de dénouement
voici une valise remplie d'espoir je la
boucle
et j'espère qu'elle sera effectivement
porteur de beaucoup d'espoir
[Musique]
il faudra 9 heures de voyage à André
pour arriver sur l'île où se trouve son
fils à 8000 km de la
[Musique]
Sainte-Lucie une ancienne colonie
britannique un petit territoire
paradisiaque situé à deux pas de la
Martinique entre océan Atlantique et
mère des Caraïbes toute l'année les
touristes du monde entier viennent
profiter de ces plages de sable fin et
d'une eau à 27 degrés
[Musique]
c'est dans ce décor de rêve kerrik le
navigateur solitaire avait décidé de
jeter son encre
Barbara l'a bien connu il venait
régulièrement boire un café ou une bière
à la terrasse de son restaurant
le bateau d'Eric était juste là-bas
il vivait de façon complètement autonome
il avait un frigidaire un congélateur sa
machine à laver tout ce dont il avait
besoin et c'est comme ça qu'il aimait
vivre avec son chien sur son bateau
une vie qui l'a choisi depuis tout jeune
loin des contraintes de la société cela
faisait 25 ans qui rit et cumet la mer
des Caraïbes sur son chalutier un navire
qu'il manœuvrait seul
à chaque escale il gagnait sa vie grâce
à des petits boulots en réparant les
bateaux des autres à l'aide de machines
outils qu'il avait en soute
[Musique]
mais cette vie d'aventurier sans
histoire va basculer en une après-midi
[Musique]
ce jour-là le 12 mai 2012
il fait une sieste sur son bateau
[Musique]
sur la plage juste en face un homme
Lucas François bois des verres de Rome
dans ce bar
l'homme serait un marginal du coin à 53
ans il serait un peu dealer un peu
vagabond il propose au tourisme de
petits services en échange de quelques
dollars
[Musique]
Buckley qui travaille sur la plage et
l'un des derniers à l'avoir vu ce
jour-là
[Musique]
sur cette plage ce jour-là avant
l'incident je l'ai vu il était tout gai
il avait bu de l'alcool et puis il était
avec cette jeune fille
quelle jeune fille
je ne me souviens pas de son nom mais
tout ce que je sais c'est qu'ils sont
partis ensemble sur un petit bateau
la jeune fille en question didri est une
amie de Lucas elle connaît aussi Eric le
français
c'est elle qui propose à Lucas François
d'aller le saluer sur son bateau en créa
300 mètres de la plage
ivre tous les deux ils prennent un
bateau taxi et se font déposer sur le
bateau d'Eric
c'est là qu'une altercation aurait
éclaté entre les deux hommes
François Lucas tombe à l'eau
[Musique]
la suite c'est un témoin clef de
l'enquête Marcus Man qui nous la raconte
il péchait au moment des faits à
quelques mètres du bateau d'Eric
il accepte de nous emmener sur les lieux
de l'incident
j'ai vu quelqu'un nager derrière le
bateau d'Eric il était tout près à un ou
deux mètres de l'embarcation et j'ai
entendu la personne criée au secours
dans la panique il remonte ses lignes et
décide de contourner le bateau d'Eric
pour porter secours à Lucas
Eric était debout sur le pont en train
de me regarder didri aussi me regarder
et comme si de rien n'était elle m'a
salué d'un grand gestamique
tout en remontant
mais qu'est-ce que vous allez faire de
lui en montrant Lucas dans l'eau et Rick
m'a répondu en hurlant [__] qu'il
aille se faire [__]
Lucas est emporté par le courant Marcus
réussi à le rejoindre 200 mètres plus
loin
je me souviendrai toujours de ce
moment-là il me regardait droit dans les
yeux puis il a commencé à couler et il
remontait plus
qu'à semble sur le point de se noyer
Marcus le récupère et de toutes ses
forces remonte son corps sur le bateau
sa tête était là son corps ici et ses
jambes pendaient à l'arrière c'est là
que je lui ai fait des massages
cardiaques pendant une bonne minute
trente c'est à ce moment là qu'il a
commencé à recracher un peu d'eau et ses
yeux ont un peu bougé
Lucas François est toujours en vie
Marcus appelle les secours qui
récupèrent la victime tout en lui
prodiguant des massages cardiaques
jusqu'à ce ponton
une ambulance lui conduit immédiatement
à l'hôpital où il meurt
mais cette mort est suspecte le
lendemain la police demande une autopsie
dont voici les conclusions
la victime est décédée par noyade
mais fait plus étonnant
les médecins relèvent des blessures sur
le torse de Lucas François 9 côtes
cassées au total
pour les enquêteurs il y aurait donc eu
une violente bagarre entre Eric et Lucas
Eric aurait blessé Lucas puis il aurait
poussé à l'eau
handicapée par ses fractures il se
serait alors noyé
ce serait donc les coups d'Eric qui
aurait provoqué la mort de Lucas il est
arrêté par la police et interrogé dans
ce commissariat pendant 5 jours sans
avocat et sans pouvoir prévenir son père
au final il est inculpé de meurtre et
conduit en prison d'où il ne sortira
plus
Eric a-t-il vraiment frappé Lucas est-il
le meurtrier
[Applaudissements]
ce matin nous retrouvons André il doit
voir Eric en prison
regarde les barbelés qui a regardé tout
seul tu vois
il est tendu et ému à la fois cela fait
trois mois qu'il n'a pas vu son fils
nous le suivons avec une caméra cachée
seul moyen d'obtenir la version d'Eric
sur ce qui s'est passé le jour du drame
qui êtes-vous pour Eric
à l'entrée tous les objets doivent être
laissés dans un casier mais la fouine ne
détectera pas notre mini caméra
Eric apparaît derrière le parloir la
vitre même brisée ne laisse passer aucun
son et il faut coller ses lèvres à une
grille métallique pour se comprendre
si on parle comme ça tu entends beaucoup
mieux tu entends bien là
tu m'entends très bien
Eric revient sur cette journée du 12 mai
2012 il admet s'être disputée avec Lucas
François mais affirme ne pas s'être
battu avec lui
le mec avec qui j'avais une altarcation
deux jours avant qu'il m'avait qui
m'avait ponctionné 20 dollars dans la
rue
j'ai regardé le mec j'ai dit quand j'ai
vu ce mec là j'étais waouh rien à faire
là et et j'ai dit dégage de là le mec
m'a rigolé à la tête je l'ai poussé même
la fille lui a dit you go et le mec sauf
il est parti à l'autre il a sauté à
l'eau le mec à tout moment il était
capable de remonter sur l'annexe ou
s'accrocher à l'annexe avec exactement
donc le mec il était il était à 10
mètres de l'annexe
aujourd'hui
eric a peur pour sa vie seul étranger
dans cette prison surpeuplée il est
victime des violences quotidiennes des
autres prisonniers
c'est chaud
c'est du matin jusqu'au soir le matin
jusqu'au soir on te dit ça
ouais
tu as des gens qui t'aiment et je sais
tu as des gens qui s'occupent
Eric n'en dira pas plus les 30 minutes
autorisées sont écoulées le père et le
fils doivent se séparer une fois de plus
[Musique]
la version d'Eric est en complète
contradiction avec celle des enquêteurs
pas de bagarre mais une simple
altercation
une version confirmée par la déposition
de Didry la jeune femme unique témoin
des faits
avez-vous vu Eric pousser la victime
eric n'a pas frappé la victime il l'a
juste poussé
si Lucas François n'a pas été frappé qui
est responsable de sa mort d'où
proviennent ces blessures
nous sommes allés voir le médecin qui a
autopsie le corps de la victime et
surprise il révèle que les fractures de
Lucas pourraient avoir été provoquées
par les massages cardiaques
quand une personne fait un massage
cardiaque et qu'elle enfonce la cage
thoracique de 2 à 5 cm
ça peut tout à fait provoquer des
fractures sur les côtes
et 9 côtes cassées ça peut arriver oui 9
côtes c'est possible vous pouvez même
avoir 6 codes fracturé de chaque côté
des précisions capitales qui pourraient
définitivement innocenté Eric mais son
procès est sans cesse repoussé
aujourd'hui
Eric doit comparaître devant les juges
qui doivent fixer la date de son procès
comment vas-tu
André Sommer seront à l'audience même
s'il n'a pas trop d'espoir voilà en
route vers le tribunal un petit peu le
l'estomac pincé
c'est toujours comme ça ouais c'est
toujours très ancien parce que je n'ai
jamais eu de le moindre point positif
nous ne suivons pas André nous ne sommes
pas autorisés à le filmer dans le
tribunal
mais nous le retrouvons deux heures plus
tard à sa sortie l'air triste et dépité
et bien ça s'est passé mal comme
d'habitude
ça continue à traîner c'est ça continue
aussi à être déprimant et ça déprime
tous les gens qui s'occupent de voir que
les mois les semestres les années
passent et que nous ne progressons pas
et nous ne savons vraiment pas
quelle sera l'issue de toutes ces de
tous ces renvois
l'audience a tourné court une fois de
plus ce soir André prend l'avion pour
retourner en France
Eric lui a déjà regagné sa prison le
prochain rendez-vous devant les juges a
lieu en décembre mais Eric et ses
proches redoutent que ce soit encore un
coup pour rien
[Musique]